it's gonna be oh no I think you let's do
that
BuzzFeed Jenga here we go
share a story about your first time
smoking weed I was like in high school
and we went into the city and I got high
and I was trying to like flirt with some
girl my opening line was like Reservoir
Dogs cool movie I was a girl I would I
would the tower told me to do that we're
killing bad ones okay yeah I'm literally
like what's Jenga get off the stage bat
mom's we're coming for you truth tell us
about your most cringe-worthy fan
experience or encounter I get a lot of
people coming up to me who just don't
know who the [ __ ] I am and they've just
seen other people come up to oh okay
look the camera and freestyle a rap song
about pizza pizza yummy I'm good
getting my tummy mmm I love that food
Hey here I'm food and good all right go
fall alright I hope this was a better
freestyling about burgers what's the
worst roommate story you've ever
experienced I was in college and my
friend got the super drunk and we had a
fan in the room and he was running to
the bathroom but he couldn't make it so
he puked into the fan and it splattered
up on the wall like blood and
and then I was it was moving out is
there any yeah you won't do or a line
you won't cross work with Mel Gibson
what is that bad
I mean we're comedy that's tricky now
pick it dude maybe we'll beat this of
all of yo the whole tables creaking are
you even though the rat like this is a
door it is all day today with me
do your best Seth Rogen laughs
impersonation what do you think from a
beautiful yeah the tower will tell you
man that's what the imaginary pole in
front of you you could erase one project
from your IMDB page would it be not the
first lifetime movie I directed which
actually was during Christmas break when
we were making this movie that was
really good how many dudes the second
one I show you that's the lesson is only
direct one lifetime movie here here
Christmas break what's the weirdest
thing you made for yourself to eat when
you were
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Ginga spoke true what was the first
expensive purchase you made after
getting your first big break and acting
I bought an Acura I remember Jud
instantly when we all did Teresa geeks
was like don't spend your this money it
might be the last money you ever made he
was very clear about that
did you about you you had a shitty car
oh yeah
yeah there was a rumor right there was a
rumor you lived at your job well that's
up to physics I think unfortunately you
should never challenged us what's the
funniest story that happened on set
while filming the disaster artist I
think was that night think that the
Tommy King showed up I interviewed Tommy
as Tommy and I was like you're gonna
direct another movie and like yeah I got
this movie very controversial they're
gonna vote it in like that movie
American Gigolo but accepted it would
gay sex very conscious never been a
movie was like yeah
19:35 walk it off yeah
try to touch your nose with your tongue
I'm so stupid do it you're not close
we're too [ __ ] good at this [ __ ] and
we have too much pride to fake this yeah
name the kardashian-jenner sisters from
oldest to youngest in under five seconds
I don't they could say all those names
under five seconds is Kim the oldest and
then crazy guys I didn't think this
might be it
we phone close too close to the Sun I'm
you know I don't see anything
structurally as a engineer this is all
we can do yeah there's no way that's the
end yeah that's it
yeah we should just embrace this and no
yeah can we just walk away champions
[Music]
[Applause]
wines away from nirvana Django thank you
[Music]